Seção 7 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações, ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite: librivox.org.
Gravado por Mayah.
Dom Casmurro, de Joaquim Maria Machado de Assis.
Capítulos XXXI a XXXV.
Capítulo XXXI As Curiosidades de Capitu
Capitu preferia tudo ao seminário. Em vez de ficar abatida com a ameaça da larga separação, se vingasse a ideia da Europa, mostrou-se satisfeita. E quando eu lhe contei o meu sonho imperial:
— Não, Bentinho, deixemos o Imperador sossegado, replicou; fiquemos por ora com a promessa de José Dias. Quando é que ele disse que falaria a sua mãe?
— Não marcou dia; prometeu que ia ver, que falaria logo que pudesse, e que me pegasse com Deus.
Capitu quis que lhe repetisse as respostas todas do agregado, as alterações do gesto e até a pirueta, que apenas lhe contara. Pedia o som das palavras. Era minuciosa e atenta; a narração e o diálogo, tudo parecia remoer consigo. Também se pode dizer que conferia, rotulava e pregava na memória a minha exposição. Esta imagem é porventura melhor que a outra, mas a ótima delas é nenhuma.
Capitu era Capitu, isto é, uma criatura muito particular, mais mulher do que eu era homem. Se ainda o não disse, aí fica. Se disse, fica também. Há conceitos que se devem incutir na alma do leitor, à força de repetição.
Era também mais curiosa. As curiosidades de Capitu dão para um capítulo. Eram de vária espécie, explicáveis e inexplicáveis, assim úteis como inúteis, umas graves, outras frívolas; gostava de saber tudo. No colégio onde, desde os sete anos, aprendera a ler, escrever e contar, francês, doutrina e obras de agulha, não aprendeu, por exemplo, a fazer renda; por isso mesmo, quis que prima Justina lhe ensinasse.
Se não estudou latim com o Padre Cabral foi porque o padre, depois de lhe propor gracejando, acabou dizendo que latim não era língua de meninas. Capitu confessou-me um dia que esta razão acendeu nela o desejo de o saber. Em compensação, quis aprender inglês com um velho professor amigo do pai e parceiro deste ao solo, mas não foi adiante. Tio Cosme ensinou-lhe gamão.
— Anda apanhar um capotinho, Capitu, dizia-lhe ele.
Capitu obedecia e jogava com facilidade, com atenção, não sei se diga com amor. Um dia fui achá-la desenhando a lápis um retrato; dava os últimos rasgos, e pediu-me que esperasse para ver se estava parecido. Era o de meu pai, copiado da tela que minha mãe tinha na sala e que ainda agora está comigo. Perfeição não era; ao contrário, os olhos saíram esbugalhados, e os cabelos eram pequenos círculos uns sobre outros.
Mas, não tendo ela rudimento algum de arte, e havendo feito aquilo de memória em poucos minutos, achei que era obra de muito merecimento; descontai-me a idade e a simpatia. Ainda assim, estou que aprenderia facilmente pintura, como aprendeu música mais tarde. Já então namorava o piano da nossa casa, velho traste inútil, apenas de estimação. Lia os nossos romances, folheava os nossos livros de gravuras, querendo saber das ruínas, das pessoas, das campanhas, o nome, a história, o lugar.
José Dias dava-lhe essas notícias com certo orgulho de erudito. A erudição deste não avultava muito mais que a sua homeopatia de Cantagalo.
Um dia, Capitu quis saber o que eram as figuras da sala de visitas. O agregado disse-lho sumariamente, demorando-se um pouco mais em César, com exclamações e latins:
— César! Júlio César! Grande homem! Tu quoque, Brute?
Capitu não achava bonito o perfil de César, mas as ações citadas por José Dias davam-lhe gestos de admiração. Ficou muito tempo com a cara virada para ele. Um homem que podia tudo! que fazia tudo! Um homem que dava a uma senhora uma pérola do valor de seis milhões de sestércios!
— E quanto valia cada sestércio?
José Dias, não tendo presente o valor do sestércio, respondeu entusiasmado:
— É o maior homem da história!
A pérola de César acendia os olhos de Capitu. Foi nessa ocasião que ela perguntou a minha mãe por que é que já não usava as jóias do retrato; referia-se ao que estava na sala, com o de meu pai; tinha um grande colar, um diadema e brincos.
— São jóias viúvas, como eu, Capitu.
— Quando é que botou estas?
— Foi pelas festas da Coroação.
— Oh! conte-me as festas da Coroação!
Sabia já o que os pais lhe haviam dito, mas naturalmente tinha para si que eles pouco mais conheceriam do que o que se passou nas ruas. Queria a notícia das tribunas da Capela Imperial e dos salões dos bailes. Nascera muito depois daquelas festas célebres. Ouvindo falar várias vezes da Maioridade, teimou um dia em saber o que fora este acontecimento; disseram-lho, e achou que o Imperador fizera muito bem em querer subir ao trono aos quinze anos.
Tudo era matéria às curiosidades de Capitu, mobílias antigas, alfaias velhas, costumes, notícias de Itaguaí, a infância e a mocidade de minha mãe, um dito daqui, uma lembrança dali, um adágio dacolá...
Capítulo XXXII Olhos de Ressaca
Tudo era matéria às curiosidades de Capitu. Caso houve, porém, no qual não sei se aprendeu ou ensinou, ou se fez ambas as coisas, como eu. É o que contarei no outro capítulo. Neste direi somente que, passados alguns dias do ajuste com o agregado, fui ver a minha amiga; eram dez horas da manhã. D. Fortunata, que estava no quintal, nem esperou que eu lhe perguntasse pela filha.
— Está na sala, penteando o cabelo, disse-me; vá devagarzinho para lhe pregar um susto.
Fui devagar, mas ou o pé ou o espelho traiu-me. Este pode ser que não fosse; era um espelhinho de pataca, perdoai a barateza, comprado a um mascate italiano, moldura tosca, argolinha de latão, pendente da parede, entre as duas janelas. Se não foi ele, foi o pé. Um ou outro, a verdade é que, apenas entrei na sala, pente, cabelos, toda ela voou pelos ares, e só lhe ouvi esta pergunta:
— Há alguma coisa?
— Não há nada, respondi; vim ver você antes que o Padre Cabral chegue para a lição. Como passou a noite?
— Eu bem. José Dias ainda não falou?
— Parece que não.
— Mas então quando fala?
— Disse-me que hoje ou amanhã pretende tocar no assunto; não vai logo de pancada, falará assim por alto e por longe, um toque. Depois, entrará em matéria. Quer primeiro ver se mamãe tem a resolução feita...
— Que tem, tem, interrompeu Capitu. E se não fosse preciso alguém para vencer já, e de todo, não se lhe falaria. Eu já nem sei se José Dias poderá influir tanto; acho que fará tudo, se sentir que você realmente não quer ser padre, mas poderá alcançar?... Ele é atendido; se, porém... É um inferno isto! Você teime com ele, Bentinho.
— Teimo; hoje mesmo ele há de falar.
— Você jura?
— Juro! Deixe ver os olhos, Capitu.
Tinha-me lembrado a definição que José Dias dera deles, “olhos de cigana oblíqua e dissimulada”. Eu não sabia o que era oblíqua, mas dissimulada sabia, e queria ver se podiam chamar assim. Capitu deixou-se fitar e examinar. Só me perguntava o que era, se nunca os vira; eu nada achei extraordinário; a cor e a doçura eram minhas conhecidas.
A demora da contemplação creio que lhe deu outra idéia do meu intento; imaginou que era um pretexto para mirá-los mais de perto, com os meus olhos longos, constantes, enfiados neles, e a isto atribuo que entrassem a ficar crescidos, crescidos e sombrios, com tal expressão que...
Retórica dos namorados, dá-me uma comparação exata e poética para dizer o que foram aqueles olhos de Capitu. Não me acode imagem capaz de dizer, sem quebra da dignidade do estilo, o que eles foram e me fizeram. Olhos de ressaca? Vá, de ressaca. É o que me dá idéia daquela feição nova. Traziam não sei que fluido misterioso e enérgico, uma força que arrastava para dentro, como a vaga que se retira da praia, nos dias de ressaca.
Para não ser arrastado, agarrei-me às outras partes vizinhas, às orelhas, aos braços, aos cabelos espalhados pelos ombros; mas tão depressa buscava as pupilas, a onda que saía delas vinha crescendo, cava e escura, ameaçando envolver-me, puxar-me e tragar-me. Quantos minutos gastamos naquele jogo? Só os relógios do Céu terão marcado esse tempo infinito e breve. A eternidade tem as suas pêndulas; nem por não acabar nunca deixa de querer saber a duração das felicidades e dos suplícios.
Há de dobrar o gozo aos bem-aventurados do Céu conhecer a soma dos tormentos que já terão padecido no inferno os seus inimigos; assim também a quantidade das delícias que terão gozado no Céu os seus desafetos aumentará as dores aos condenados do inferno. Este outro suplício escapou ao divino Dante; mas eu não estou aqui para emendar poetas.
Estou para contar que, ao cabo de um tempo não marcado, agarrei-me definitivamente aos cabelos de Capitu, mas então com as mãos, e disse-lhe, para dizer alguma coisa, que era capaz de os pentear, se quisesse.
— Você?
— Eu mesmo.
— Vai embaraçar-me o cabelo todo, isso sim.
— Se embaraçar, você desembaraça depois.
— Vamos ver.
Capítulo XXXIII O Penteado
Capitu deu-me as costas, voltando-se para o espelhinho. Peguei-lhe dos cabelos, colhi-os todos e entrei a alisá-los com o pente, desde a testa até as últimas pontas, que lhe desciam à cintura. Em pé não dava jeito: não esquecestes que ela era um nadinha mais alta que eu, mas ainda que fosse da mesma altura. Pedi-lhe que se sentasse.
— Senta aqui, é melhor.
Sentou-se. “Vamos ver o grande cabeleireiro”, disse-me rindo. Continuei a alisar os cabelos, com muito cuidado, e dividi-os em duas porções iguais, para compor as duas tranças. Não as fiz logo, nem assim depressa, como podem supor os cabeleireiros de ofício, mas devagar, devagarinho, saboreando pelo tato aqueles fios grossos, que eram parte dela. O trabalho era atrapalhado, às vezes por desazo, outras de propósito para desfazer o feito e refazê-lo.
Os dedos roçavam na nuca da pequena ou nas espáduas vestidas de chita, e a sensação era um deleite. Mas, enfim, os cabelos iam acabando, por mais que eu os quisesse intermináveis.
Não pedi ao Céu que eles fossem tão longos como os da Aurora, porque não conhecia ainda esta divindade que os velhos poetas me apresentaram depois; mas, desejei penteá-los por todos os séculos dos séculos, tecer duas tranças que pudessem envolver o infinito por um número inominável de vezes.
Se isto vos parecer enfático, desgraçado leitor, é que nunca penteastes uma pequena, nunca pusestes as mãos adolescentes na jovem cabeça de uma ninfa... Uma ninfa! Todo eu estou mitológico. Ainda há pouco, falando dos seus olhos de ressaca, cheguei a escrever Tétis; risquei Tétis, risquemos ninfa; digamos somente uma criatura amada, palavra que envolve todas as potências cristãs e pagãs.
Enfim, acabei as duas tranças. Onde estava a fita para atar-lhes as pontas? Em cima da mesa, um triste pedaço de fita enxovalhada. Juntei as pontas das tranças, uni-as por um laço, retoquei a obra alargando aqui, achatando ali, até que exclamei:
— Pronto!
— Estará bom?
— Veja no espelho.
Em vez de ir ao espelho, que pensais que fez Capitu? Não vos esqueçais que estava sentada, de costas para mim. Capitu derreou a cabeça, a tal ponto que me foi preciso acudir com as mãos e ampará-la; o espaldar da cadeira era baixo. Inclinei-me depois sobre ela, rosto a rosto, mas trocados, os olhos de uma na linha da boca do outro. Pedi-lhe que levantasse a cabeça, podia ficar tonta, machucar o pescoço.
Cheguei a dizer-lhe que estava feia; mas nem esta razão a moveu.
— Levanta, Capitu!
Não quis, não levantou a cabeça, e ficamos assim a olhar um para o outro, até que ela abrochou os lábios, eu desci os meus, e...
Grande foi a sensação do beijo; Capitu ergueu-se, rápida, eu recuei até à parede com uma espécie de vertigem, sem fala, os olhos escuros. Quando eles me clarearam, vi que Capitu tinha os seus no chão. Não me atrevi a dizer nada; ainda que quisesse, faltava-me língua. Preso, atordoado, não achava gesto nem ímpeto que me descolasse da parede e me atirasse a ela com mil palavras cálidas e mimosas... Não mofes dos meus quinze anos, leitor precoce.
Com dezessete, Des Grieux, e mais era Des Grieux, não pensava ainda na diferença dos sexos.
Capítulo XXXIV Sou Homem!
Ouvimos passos no corredor; era D. Fortunata. Capitu compôs-se depressa, tão depressa que, quando a mãe apontou à porta, ela abanava a cabeça e ria. Nenhum laivo amarelo, nenhuma contração de acanhamento, um riso espontâneo e claro, que ela explicou por estas palavras alegres:
— Mamãe, olhe como este senhor cabeleireiro me penteou; pediu-me para acabar o penteado, e fez isto. Veja que tranças!
— Que tem? acudiu a mãe, transbordando de benevolência. Está muito bem, ninguém dirá que é de pessoa que não sabe pentear.
— O que, mamãe? Isto? redarguiu Capitu, desfazendo as tranças. Ora, mamãe!
E com um enfadamento gracioso e voluntário que às vezes tinha, pegou do pente e alisou os cabelos para renovar o penteado. D. Fortunata chamou-lhe tonta, e disse-me que não fizesse caso, não era nada, maluquices da filha. Olhava com ternura para mim e para ela. Depois, parece-me que desconfiou. Vendo-me calado, enfiado, cosido à parede, achou talvez que houvera entre nós algo mais que penteado, e sorriu por dissimulação...
Como eu quisesse falar também para disfarçar o meu estado, chamei algumas palavras cá de dentro, e elas acudiram de pronto, mas de atropelo, e encheram-me a boca sem poder sair nenhuma. O beijo de Capitu fechava-me os lábios. Uma exclamação, um simples artigo, por mais que investissem com força, não logravam romper de dentro. E todas as palavras recolheram-se ao coração, murmurando: “Eis aqui um que não fará grande carreira no mundo, por menos que as emoções o dominem...”
Assim, apanhados pela mãe, éramos dois e contrários, ela encobrindo com a palavra o que eu publicava pelo silêncio. D. Fortunata tirou-me daquela hesitação, dizendo que minha mãe me mandara chamar para a lição de latim; o Padre Cabral estava à minha espera. Era uma saída; despedi-me e enfiei pelo corredor. Andando, ouvi que a mãe censurava as maneira da filha, mas a filha não dizia nada.
Corri ao meu quarto, peguei dos livros, mas não passei à sala da lição; sentei-me na cama, recordando o penteado e o resto. Tinha estremeções, tinha uns esquecimentos em que perdia a consciência de mim e das coisas que me rodeavam, para viver não sei onde nem como. E tornava a mim, e via a cama, as paredes, os livros, o chão, ouvia algum som de fora, vago, próximo ou remoto, e logo perdia tudo para sentir somente os beiços de Capitu...
Sentia-os estirados, embaixo dos meus, igualmente esticados para os dela, e unindo-se uns aos outros. De repente, sem querer, sem pensar, saiu-me da boca esta palavra de orgulho:
— Sou homem!
Supus que me tivessem ouvido, porque a palavra saiu em voz alta, e corri à porta da alcova. Não havia ninguém fora. Voltei para dentro e, baixinho, repeti que era homem. Ainda agora tenho o eco aos meus ouvidos. O gosto que isto me deu foi enorme. Colombo não o teve maior, descobrindo a América, e perdoai a banalidade em favor do cabimento; com efeito, há em cada adolescente um mundo encoberto, um almirante e um Sol de outubro.
Fiz outros achados mais tarde; nenhum me deslumbrou tanto. A denúncia de José Dias alvoroçara-me, a lição do velho coqueiro também, a vista dos nossos nomes abertos por ela no muro do quintal deu-me grande abalo, como vistes; nada disso valeu a sensação do beijo. Podiam ser mentira ou ilusão. Sendo verdade, eram os ossos da verdade, não eram a carne e o sangue dela. As próprias mãos, tocadas, apertadas, como que fundidas, não podiam dizer tudo.
— Sou homem!
Quando repeti isto, pela terceira vez, pensei no seminário, mas como se pensa em perigo que passou, um mal abortado, um pesadelo extinto; todos os meus nervos me disseram que homens não são padres. O sangue era da mesma opinião. Outra vez senti os beiços de Capitu. Talvez abuso um pouco das reminiscências osculares; mas a saudade é isto mesmo; é o passar e repassar das memórias antigas.
Ora, de todas as daquele tempo creio que a mais doce é esta, a mais nova, a mais compreensiva, a que inteiramente me revelou a mim mesmo. Outras tenho, vastas e numerosas, doces também, de vária espécie, muitas intelectuais, igualmente intensas. Grande homem que fosse, a recordação era menor que esta.
Capítulo XXXV O Protonotário Apostólico
Enfim, peguei dos livros e corri à lição. Não corri precisamente; a meio caminho parei, advertindo que devia ser muito tarde, e podiam ler-me no semblante alguma coisa. Tive ideia de mentir, alegar uma vertigem que me houvesse deitado ao chão; mas o susto que causaria a minha mãe fez-me rejeitá-la. Pensei em prometer algumas dezenas de padre-nossos; tinha, porém, outra promessa em aberto e outro favor pendente... Não, vamos ver; fui andando, ouvi vozes alegres, conversavam ruidosamente.
Quando entrei na sala, ninguém ralhou comigo.
O Padre Cabral recebera na véspera um recado do internúncio; foi ter com ele, e soube que, por decreto pontifício, acabava de ser nomeado protonotário apostólico. Esta distinção do papa dera-lhe grande contentamento e a todos os nossos.
Tio Cosme e prima Justina repetiam o título com admiração; era a primeira vez que ele soava aos nossos ouvidos, acostumados a cônegos, monsenhores, bispos, núncios, e internúncios; mas que era protonotário apostólico? O Padre Cabral explicou que não era propriamente o cargo da cúria, mas as honras dele. Tio Cosme viu exalçar-se no parceiro de voltarete, e repetia:
— Protonotário apostólico!
E voltando-se para mim:
— Prepara-te, Bentinho; tu podes vir a ser protonotário apostólico.
Cabral ouvia com gosto a repetição do título. Estava em pé, dava alguns passos, sorria ou tamborilava na tampa da boceta. O tamanho do título como que lhe dobrava a magnificência, posto que, para ligá-lo ao nome, era demasiado comprido; esta segunda reflexão foi tio Cosme que a fez. Padre Cabral acudiu que não era preciso dizê-lo todo, bastava que lhe chamassem o protonotário Cabral. Subentendia-se apostólico.
— Protonotário Cabral.
— Sim, tem razão; protonotário Cabral.
— Mas, Sr. protonotário, acudiu prima Justina para se ir acostumando ao uso do título, isto o obriga a ir a Roma?
— Não, D. Justina.
— Não, são só as honras, observou minha mãe.
— Agora, não impede, disse Cabral, que continuava a refletir, não impede que nos casos de maior formalidade, atos públicos, cartas de cerimônia, etc.; se empregue o título inteiro: protonotário apostólico. No uso comum, basta protonotário.
— Justamente, assentiram todos.
José Dias, que entrou pouco depois de mim, aplaudia a distinção, e recordou, a propósito, os primeiros atos políticos de Pio IX, grandes esperanças da Itália; mas ninguém pegou do assunto; o principal da hora e do lugar era o meu velho mestre de latim. Eu, voltando a mim do receio, entendi que devia cumprimentá-lo também, e este aplauso não lhe foi menos ao coração que os outros. Bateu-me na bochecha paternalmente, e acabou dando-me férias.
Era muita felicidade para uma só hora. Um beijo e férias! Creio que o meu rosto disse isto mesmo, porque tio Cosme, sacudindo a barriga, chamou-me peralta; mas José Dias corrigiu a alegria:
— Não tem que festejar a vadiação; o latim sempre lhe há de ser preciso, ainda que não venha a ser padre.
Conheci aqui o meu homem. Era a primeira palavra, a semente lançada à terra, assim de passagem, como para acostumar os ouvidos da família. Minha mãe sorriu para mim, cheia de amor e de tristeza, mas respondeu logo:
— Há de ser padre, e padre bonito.
— Não se esqueça, mana Glória, e protonotário também. Protonotário apostólico.
— O protonotário Santiago, acentuou Cabral.
Se a intenção do meu mestre de latim era ir acostumando ao uso do título com o nome, não sei bem; o que sei é que quando ouvi o meu nome ligado a tal título, deu-me vontade de dizer um desaforo. Mas a vontade aqui foi antes uma ideia, uma ideia sem língua, que se deixou ficar quieta e muda, tal como daí a pouco outras ideias... Mas essas pedem um capítulo especial. Rematemos este dizendo que o mestre de latim falou algum tempo da minha ordenação eclesiástica, ainda que sem grande interesse.
Ele buscava um assunto alheio para se mostrar esquecido da própria glória, mas era esta que o deslumbrava na ocasião. Era um velho magro, sereno, dotado de qualidades boas. Alguns defeitos tinha; o mais excelso deles era ser guloso, não propriamente glutão; comia pouco, mas estimava o fino e o raro, e a nossa cozinha, se era simples, era menos pobre que a dele.
Assim, quando minha mãe lhe disse que viesse jantar, a fim de se lhe fazer uma saúde, os olhos com que aceitou seriam de protonotário, mas não eram apostólicos. E para agradar a minha mãe, novamente pegou em mim, descrevendo o meu futuro eclesiástico, e queria saber se ia para o seminário agora, no ano próximo, e oferecia-se a falar ao “senhor bispo”, tudo marchetado do “protonotário Santiago.”
Fim da seção 7.
Gravado por Mayah.